[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are here
in New York City at the launch of
American Express's new live life
campaign it's a global brand campaign
that's all about balancing our personal
lives our work lives we all got so much
going on and I spoke to a woman who does
it all very well miss Jessica Biel it
was really important for me to partner
with American Express on the Live Life
campaign because it is my life I am
constantly trying to blend my personal
in my work together on a daily basis not
always succeeding and I just love this
idea of inspiring people and celebrating
the moments when anyone can say you know
what I'm taking a break this times for
me this hours for me this exercise is
for me whatever it is that you need as a
human to rejuvenate yourself and
honestly it will get you ready to go
back to the responsibilities of your
life so I just I really believe in the
campaign I think it's important and it's
just it's very organic for me
ét partnered with American Express to
check out the launch event which
included an interactive exhibit filled
with experiences we traveled we ate
delicious food we even played with
puppies it was all about work and play
you have your career Justin's career
being parents yourself how do you find
those little moments for yourself with
all you have going on even if it's 30
minutes by myself just doing some some
exercise and some mental exercise would
be a great moment for me or reading a
book thanks so much for watching you
guys you can head to American Express
comm slash live life to get so much more
on this campaign